Sabe qual é o dia mais perigoso da
semana pro seu coração? Pois é,
segunda-feira. E não é brincadeira, não
tem ciência por trás disso. Olha só,
pesquisadores da Irlanda e do Reino
Unido analisaram mais de 10.000 casos de
infarto e descobriram que o risco
aumenta 13% nas segundas-feiras. 13%. É
muita coisa. E não é coincidência não,
viu? Veja bem, o que acontece é o
seguinte. Nosso corpo sente o trampo da
mudança brusca de rotina. Domingo você
tá relaxado, dormir até mais tarde. Aí
segunda bate aquele despertador, o
cortisol dispara, a pressão sobe. Soma
isso com um final de semana que muita
gente exagera na bebida, come mal, dorme
pouco, às vezes fuma. É a tempestade
perfeita pro infarto. E tem mais, o
estresse de voltar pro trabalho,
especialmente se você não curte o que
faz ou trabalha no ambiente tóxico, isso
tudo inflama seu corpo. Seu coração
literalmente sofre com a segunda-feira.
Então fica a dica. Que tal repensar como
você vive seu domingo? Mantém uma rotina
de sono, pega leve no álcool, não deixa
o exercício só pra semana. Seu coração
agradece na segunda. E se seu trabalho
tá te matando, literalmente, talvez seja
a hora de repensar isso também. Yeah.